wait offering you
you know it had his address so i just
wrote him you know you can literally
just write this guy right and send him
your film and see what happens you know
and at the time he was kind of done with
with repping you know independent think
crumb was one of the thought that terry
zwigoff doc was one of the last things
he be prepped um and then you know he
would give these it was almost like a
grant program if he liked an idea if he
liked the filmmaker he had this
half-hour show three segments he
literally I'd never met the guy never i
still have never physically met the guy
the guy wrote me a check without meeting
me to do my what was in the letter that
what was so well liked how did you
remember the life I do I mean it was you
know I sent him a film I just done that
was like a real no budget feature that
was not great but you know he responded
that he liked my letter been in like
film but it was it was a handwritten
note that was as witty as I could be you
know saying it uh you know what I've
made here kind of looks feels and sounds
like a film I don't know you be the
judge and I just you know tried to be um
you know just different you know and I
think that just uh you know that
captured him a little bit you know and
and based on that letter not on the
phone but more on the letter he write to
a check how much was the check it was
like 3500 for I was gonna be a
seven-minute segments it morphed into
something much more because we shot you
know and then I had to put some of my
own money into